[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
these boys
could not be more careful
we've been pretty good i i think that
because of the state of how the world is
like we've been extremely careful and
we've been dancing around topics in a
very respectful way spreading awareness
and peace of love joy and respect
and unity
joy and respect yeah i like the joy part
yeah that's the yeah i hear that as much
and also making hard news very enjoyable
and standing up for the rights of people
who can't stand up for themselves i
think that's what that's what really i'm
proud of myself about and taking heart
anthony yeah mainly him well taking
hardline stances on topics that are
really extremely difficult to talk about
yeah definitely you know what i mean you
gotta actually go into a good joke it
can't just be a recurring thing
it gets really boring anthony's grumpy
huh
i'm grumpy what's going on
um
this is what i wanted to know since you
guys have learned so much in your lives
if you had to go back to your high
school and give a seminar to the kids of
today
what would you say oh i can't wait bro
but they never want me back i [ __ ]
email every single school that i got
kicked out of
dropped out
and i say dude check this out like i'm a
great success story of a proposition let
me go back let me talk
to the kids knock some sense into these
sons of [ __ ]
and i'll [ __ ] make sure that you'll
have a higher percentage of successful
students you know what anything's going
on they don't they don't even message me
i think they're just reading your email
[Laughter]
just now
and i think they just read it and
they're like oh yeah we definitely don't
want those yeah
like i have all knocked some respect in
these sons of [ __ ] like
i think they're just reading it where do
you think those kids are going wrong
that they need to be too they might be
like hey you got to see this email yeah
that's true
i just want to tell them to get the [ __ ]
out of that place as soon as possible
[ __ ] yeah that's probably why they're
not bringing you like drop out or
graduate or no get out go just walk down
what are you doing you need this what's
the next step for these kids that
they're all just believing yeah let's
get out they get out they're like then
what what if these kids listen to your
every word what's their name what grade
are we talking to i think that six to
eight sixth to eighth grade
oh at junior high school i haven't
thought about that yet dude i haven't
thought about that no no no no but but
real talk though i get uh a call from my
you one of my favorite things to do okay
graduated from cal state la i always get
a call from them asking if i would like
to donate and things like that
my favorite thing to do
is
to tell them no
that's it i'm not using my degree [ __ ]
you
oh wow
okay what was your degree again
psychology you don't think you're using
psychology no it's a bachelor's you
can't do [ __ ] with that and i didn't pay
attention as hard but i still got good
grades and i judge the school system
because i'm like i should have to work
my ass off for those straight a's
i should have to like i should the work
ethics that you learn in the real world
college is too [ __ ] easy and maybe
it's just that yeah you're right yeah i
agree it's too [ __ ] easy yeah at cal
state la
right you know who relates to you right
now college students they're going this
shit's too easy this thing i'm stressing
out about yeah every night it's just
what so easy give me something hard
in the moment i thought it was the
hardest thing i've ever done
and then um you live life and you go
[ __ ] this is a fake world because this
is a [ __ ] isn't that the point
though to like
edge in slowly you know what i mean not
dump it all on you at one time
i think what happened was i grew up too
early in high school
and i saw some adult [ __ ] and then when
i went back to college i was like this
is [ __ ] easy bro
yeah cal state l.a yeah you should have
known that joe was seeing some real
adult [ __ ] so if you went back and spoke
at cal state l.a you would tell them to
get out he told him it's easy nah to be
honest i'm just [ __ ] with you guys i
think a lot of people actually need
school
but
when it comes down to the economics of
everything i think it's horrible so like
back when i was going to college um the
financial aid and all those things were
still really good so you could
practically get out of school without
too much debt in your you know
i mean obviously you have to consider in
like what kind of major you're in you
might be like going into the medical
field you might be doing like a you know
doctorate and you might rack up bills
that way which is still a hefty price
but it was still a reasonable rate where
like you know you go to school you can
get a good degree that will get you a
good job and you can pay off that loan
um because it was reasonable but right
now
i mean dude you're getting a [ __ ]
degree in humanities or like [ __ ] i
don't know like journalism or some [ __ ]
and then you're gonna be in debt for a
hundred grand after you graduate that's
[ __ ] crazy and for those reason i
would say
damn watch out for those call like don't
what like how much is your degree gonna
cost you watch out if you don't have a
parent paying for that [ __ ] be careful
so just for the for that aspect i'd be
like watch out for school
but other than that
so you go back to like seventh and
eighth graders and tell them to watch
out college college yeah yeah yeah
but if i don't know
you guys talk i'll i'll talk later
what would you tell them junior higher
or the college either one either one you
pick man that's tough dude because you
know when you like when you feel like
you have good advice because you went
through it
but then you're like man these
[ __ ] are too dumb to even know
what i'm talking about
because i was dumb too you know what i
mean if you're like if you're like how
do you it's like how do you give good
life advice to someone that's getting a
boat or every three minutes when they're
staring at you and they're not even
attracted to you
that's true confusing it was so hard for
me to pay attention in junior high
because just having [ __ ] boners and
you got the craziest 80d like i would
see people like rip their the gum
wrapper the foil and then put it on the
binder and i'm like you could do that
that's [ __ ] crazy man i'm probably
learning about some crazy ass science
newton's law [ __ ] but i wasn't
paying attention because i saw some guy
putting [ __ ] gun wrappers on his
binder that looked like the cool thing
to do
that is pretty cool so how do you
compete with that you know you can so i
want to have a good message but i want
it to be received so maybe i'll go to
the college route best thing is though
is that nothing we're going to say is
original anyway because like everybody
[ __ ] says the same [ __ ] all the time
like think about i think about my high
school valedictorian who not i wasn't
the valedictorian but the person who was
talking and they're like
[ __ ] up make mistakes and everyone's
like god damn this is gonna be [ __ ]
that's true i wish someone was like yo
man
[ __ ] cal state santa barbara's or
some [ __ ] or like
that's cool
but nothing's going to teach you like
life will they i want them to come out
and be like in high school they're like
check this out
all the best parties are at ucr and then
if you want to [ __ ]
if you want to [ __ ] really uh go out
and [ __ ] a lot then you go to uc san
francisco or whatever right and i'm like
ah
you're speaking my language
i love house parties
cal state pomona baby you know like i
know what school you know what i wish
they taught me i wish they would have
taught me to
find out what you want to do
and then reverse engineer the way to get
there right like if you want to be a
comedian just probably go to improv
school take some stand-up classes or
whatever or if you like [ __ ] parties
maybe you figure out a way to get like
in the insomniac crew so you could throw
like big-ass parties like edc versus i
think the way that's taught in school is
you jump into the method without even
knowing what the result is so the goal
is get into college get skills yeah it's
the method and then you explore within
the method but that's weird that's like
saying like
go go to the gym
and then figure out what you want to do
with your body no like figure out what
you want to do with your body do you
want to be a boxer do you want to have a
six pack what do you want to do and then
now find the way of training to help you
get to that result rather than just do
for the sake of doing just rep that's
right the thing is with usually like we
still talking about college we talking
about before college whatever you want
because i think not before college cause
they have boners too much
yeah that's true though well then i
guess i respect kids never mind dude um
did you ever have an army recruiter or
marine speak at your school when you're
a kid uh i remember taking what are
those things called the [ __ ] of
satinizer so i'm sure everyone's taking
in the cafeteria like those standardized
tests to see star testing or story or
whatever those things are
and i remember like there would be
recruiters walking around oh but they
never gave a speech about like or they
[ __ ] set up a a pull-up bar or they
bring a hummer in with yeah they would
do the pull-up bar but they're bad
they bring a hammer in with subwoofers
and [ __ ]
is that what you're talking about
pandering rotc right maybe yeah usually
like rotcs uh on campus and stuff we
didn't have rotc in our schools i just
don't know what if i've ever listened to
a speech before i'm going and gone man
i learned so much from that speech
especially at that eight yeah sometimes
i i remember i remember having like a
moment of like damn that guy's so right
and then
you start playing basketball and then
you go home and you [ __ ] eat dinner
you jack off and then tomorrow you
forget exactly any of that [ __ ] exactly
and i i i don't know maybe i'm just dumb
as [ __ ] but i feel like most people all
the way up until college never take
nothing serious and don't also have the
discipline to even execute when they're
inspired because nothing teaches you
like life does that's what i'm saying
like because you can hear the speech you
can get the inspiration it's temporary
it's fleeting it'll go away but you you
when you go through [ __ ] in life you
actually build
the methods that you can get over
obstacles with but but hearing somebody
talk about it isn't gonna cement it the
same way that's cool is that there's one
guy that when i was in third grade he
came to my school and spoke and i never
forgot this advice that he gave today's
video is brought to you by bombash
mission is simple to make the most
comfortable clothes ever and match every
item sold with an equal item donated so
when you're buying bone busts you're
also giving it to someone in need boom
box designs their socks shirt and
underwear to be the clothes you can't
wait to put on every day everything they
make is soft seamless tagless it has a
luxuriously cozy feel they're made from
super soft materials like merino wool
pima cotton and even cashmere which
makes them the perfect cozy layers
there's a pair of bomba socks for
everything that you do they come in tons
of options like comfy performance styles
for every sport or activity that keeps
you moving bumbus t-shirts are made with
thoughtful design features like
invisible seams soft fabrics and the
perfect weight so they hang just right
bombas underwear has a barely their feel
but second skin support that might make
you forget they're even there in a good
way and did you know that socks
underwear and t-shirts are the three
most requested clothing items at
homeless shelters that's why bone bust
donates one for every item that you buy
go to bonebus.com off the record to get
20 off your first order that's b o m b a
s dot com slash off director to get 20
off bumbus.com
off the record
because this dude did it in the most
genius way possible he was this like
like 350 pound like fat dude that i
guess he collected um like animals or
some [ __ ] and so he's just like he's
barely mobile he's like sitting his
thing
we're in like an assembly auditorium and
he's talking he puts he gets a scorpion
and just sticks it on his face and the
scorpion's just like chilling on his
face
and then after he does that he goes
do not let anyone tell you
that you can't learn something
and i never [ __ ] forgot it damn
that's pretty cool
isn't that the most effective way to
speak to like a kid i was in third grade
and i was like
holy [ __ ] and then he just proceeded to
like talk about like there's no limit to
knowledge whatever you choose to do you
can do it you can do multiple things you
don't have to focus on one you can do
anything you want
i think i'm the kid who sits there and
goes um i don't know if i'm listening to
scorpion face guys
he spoke to me
yeah supposed to be because i feel like
i see these [ __ ] ten squares and i'm
like you got a guy with the scorpion i'm
like i want to be that guy
third grade third grade i would have
been the kid like excuse me why are you
so fat
there's there's kids like that i do
think though that like when you're an
impressionable um at that age like you
gotta
speak that language if you want that
person to understand what you're talking
about it's got to be you know your room
i remember um a sub came into econ class
one time and taught me more about
life than the entire [ __ ] class and
i'll never forget too he's like he lady
comes in and he's like hey so i just
want to let you guys know that um you're
allowed to cheat
you're allowed to cheat in here and
already i was like what the [ __ ] you
doing huh and then he goes
as long as you don't get caught
you get caught you want a great trouble
other than that
and then i was like uh in my mind i was
like i know there are like elements that
are wrong about this did he have his
chair turned around and sitting like
this when he was talking
but ultimately i'm like that peep game
that like changed my understanding you
know what i mean
hey guys let me tell you something about
it just made it real it just made it a
lot like oh let me try and like outsmart
this teacher or whatever and blah blah
it just made it like okay cool like that
is the relationship that we all have and
everybody's smart enough to know that
that exists and it's like cool i don't
want to get caught you're right you know
what i'm saying yeah that's no in the
room for sure which i guess is i guess
what i'm saying is uh that's what
speeches do right like of course i think
you guys are right most people don't
give a [ __ ] about those speeches
but chances are if like that one person
gets something from it that one person
is probably actually going to be running
like the corporation that most of these
people are working at anyway you know
what i'm saying so it's like kind of all
that matters yeah i think the ones that
really spoke to me or if i do go back i
would want to
talk about the realness of like um
how kids probably are feeling in high
school with the whole depression and
wanting to kill themselves and
everything because everyone thinks that
they're so
special
like when you're at that age you think
you are you you have a [ __ ] up haircut
and you feel like everyone's looking at
you no one gives a [ __ ] about you dude
but then like you really are a goddamn
narcissist when you're like young right
you think oh i can't go to school man
it's all over dude my sweaters [ __ ]
shrink now they're gonna make fun of me
dude my life is over and you're a
narcissist and you probably look up to a
narcissist who's like on tick-tock
yeah i think i would structure
my speech in a way where i want to make
them feel like
you know like dude this is it's normal
and then you'll get over it because like
i think when you're in your head at that
age that's why there is like teenage
suicide and self-destructive behavior
and drowning themselves in drugs because
they're trying to
i don't know like ease the pain of the
[ __ ] that they're going through not
knowing that this is just a part of it
like it sucks but it's a part of you
know
going down the rabbit hole of negative
thinking and whatever and it's just a
part of being human and when you're in
high school and you have all these
hormones going around like you go
through a dark place you might do that
and i think that's that's something that
no one really talks about and maybe i
probably do if i do get up there and
like talk about it is like yeah dude
life's gonna [ __ ] suck like heavily
you might want to kill yourself right
now whatever but it does get better you
know
yeah i'm not bringing you into my high
school no way i like the idea of telling
kids that like you might want to kill
yourselves or just a mixture between
both of your things where it's like you
guys want to keep yourselves good
that's good just know that if you do
you're going to get a a huge
bunch of trouble
just know if you do you're gonna be dead
but your seat has to be backwards you're
gonna be [ __ ] busted you kill
yourself gonna be busted
it's like a 90s like i'm a rebel teacher
kind of [ __ ] he comes in with a boombox
chewing gum
blowing it
but that [ __ ] did resonate with me when
i was a kid like if a sub came in and
they were just like younger and cooler
yeah it you it did resonate hotter big
boobs and then later you realize that
that guy was so lame oh yeah he was fine
but it was age appropriate at the time
that's true i remember for my college uh
graduation our keynote speaker was um
the bass player for lincoln park what
that's dope cause that was his alma
mater and he came up like all square
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] suit and you can have
like a piece of paper and he's like kind
of like shaking and he was we and he was
like reading the words he was like [ __ ]
that i was just kidding he just ripped
it up he tore off his suit and he had a
ucla jersey underneath and he just
started talking to people and then like
all of a sudden everyone that was like
this stuff like speech
was like oh [ __ ] he's talking to us like
normal people and that was i forgot what
he said but just that impression of like
you can be successful and be a human
being was was cool yeah yeah especially
at that age all the teachers or the
mentors that you talked to the ones that
you really enjoyed were the ones that
actually talked to like
just a normal person they didn't talk to
like an adult talking to a kid i think
they know their audience yeah they know
how to like just communicate they're
effective communicators at the end i
wonder how like um military recruiters
like because i'm sure they all have
their own individual like skills on how
they get their person to sign up but
like the one that came to my school did
not do a good job
what do you do he was just talking about
like what the process is like for boot
camp
and everybody was like [ __ ] that
you want to starve dude
[Laughter]
people were dying boot camp every
[ __ ] year it was like it's called
helicopter
all i remember is like my impression of
it was very negative and like the
standout thing that i remember him
saying was like
yeah so there was a time where we all
had to uh
your your task is to go underwater with
another uh person and inflict pain
before you both drown
and i was like inflict pain before we
drown like what does that even mean that
guy's not meeting his quotas yeah yeah
yeah
there's one kid in there who's like see
green who like graduated from my high
school and he came back to talk to the
kids about it oh he went to that house i
went to that high school yeah our high
school it would say gabriel yeah if i
could tell kids something that that has
resonated for me
it's that every room i've been in no
matter where i've ever been
everyone doesn't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing
i cannot emphasize that enough to people
i was at a company saying about it
but but everyone's figuring out as they
go yeah like if you could learn anything
i swear to god it's that nobody knows
what the [ __ ] they're doing everyone's
making up as they go along even the cats
at disney are going like yeah i think
i [ __ ] know yeah this is some new age
[ __ ] this is worth a billion dollars
right
and so so those cats meanwhile at disney
right they sell that place
they end up you know actually acquiring
the company then finding out like oh my
god what the [ __ ] is all this what did
we buy yeah they they popped the hood
like jesus christ there was no engine
and in the guys
and then the guys that bought it are
probably working for apple now no
they're not even at disney anymore yeah
oh and they got shuffled somewhere else
nobody [ __ ] fails everyone fails up
if anything that is that is a that is a
hardcore truth of reality that might be
the number one key right headless
[ __ ] chickens everywhere everywhere
from top to bottom everywhere nobody
knows what the [ __ ] they're doing
as they go that's it that is so good
because there is no exact way to do
something otherwise everyone will just
do it to the letter and they don't
nobody can because there's such
different factors and circumstances for
everybody yeah and just depends on where
the [ __ ] you are too yeah so that's why
the worst thing about people who give
speeches like that and um
that's all they did was kind of
freestyle their way through it but then
in retrospect they put the pieces
together differently and they say they
did it a different way but it's like
that's probably how you think you did it
but the reality of it was way more
[ __ ] ad-libbed yeah and people hardly
ever tell anybody that dude mark cuban
sold broadcast.com to yahoo for billions
of dollars right
that it was a [ __ ] joke
broadcast.com was a [ __ ] joke bro
there was they had like a couple of
things going on but it was like a
[ __ ] joke but mark cuban wasn't a
joke no he wasn't and he was a good
salesman and that's why he's worth the
billions right so but the company that
he sold was was a result of excellent
craftsmanship and just hitting the
market at the right time and but
i would do what the [ __ ] they were doing
what happened after you sold it who
bought it like what whatever became of
it after they bought it go go look at
broadcast.com right now exactly what
happened afterwards mark cuban got of no
never air 404
i forgot who said this go daddy
now buy this
redirect me to angel fire
[Music]
so